hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be looking at the whale opening
which starts out with e4 e5
c4 now you can see that white's looking
to control the central light squares was
also giving up the dark square
specifically the d4 square in this video
we're going to look at four variations
from black we're going to look at knight
to c6 we're going to look at knight to
f6 bishop to c5 as well as c6 and i'll
give you some ideas on how white can
actually do a good job of controlling
not only the central light squares but
also counter attacking if black does try
to
control this d4 and central dark squares
hopefully guys enjoy this video
this video is brought to you by
skillshare more from them later in the
video
the first version we're going to look at
is knight to c6 you can see that black
is already preparing to bring his knight
to d4 and really control this d4 square
white's not able to kick this knight
away with its pawn would have to do so
with a different piece now you'll see a
common theme throughout this and that
really starts with the move d3
yes this does block off the light square
bishop on f1 but the light square bishop
was already blocked off so you don't
have to worry too much about that but
what does
allow white to do is open up for the
dark square bishop to get involved into
the game this queen can now come to
either side the queen side or the king
side and it doesn't block off the knight
on c3 which is going to be a pretty
common square for white to go to
now there's really two common ways that
black can respond the first one is
bishop to c5 the other one is knight to
f6 so we'll first look at bishop to c5
just putting all of the pieces eyeing
down on this d4 square now from here
white's going to play bishop to e3 and
this is really the key move in this
entire opening if you want to play from
whites you have to be playing bishop to
e3 if not i think you're just going to
get overrun
on this d4 square
now the reason you play this is because
if they want to exchange here
then white has a pretty good setup it's
not too bad if you have double pawns on
the same file
if they're in the center as well as if
they have pawns connecting so this
d-pawn on d3 being next to these double
pawns on the e-file just make it very
difficult for black to do anything in
the center of the board you can see that
all of a sudden white has four pawns in
the center three of which are on the d
and e file and black right now only has
one pawn in the center with e5 so how
does black really control this d4 square
where well they really don't and so
that's where it becomes tricky now from
here if they wanted to play queen to h4
that's fine attacking the king but then
we just play pawn
g3
the queen comes back to h6 we play queen
to d2 uh and things are fine knight to
f6 you can see knight c3 here but
there's no real way to break open the
center we just have so many pawns
defending it now with our queen here so
it doesn't matter if the castle on the
king side knight to f3 this is all
pretty good set up for for white now
maybe they don't bring their queen out
but if they don't knight to f6 here
can continue the same thought press
knight to f3
uh maybe pawn d6 opening up for the
light square bishop to get involved into
the game pinning down our knight that's
definitely a possibility but we could
play bishop to e2 we can castle on the
king side very similar to a king's
gambit where you have the f file
semi-open where you can castle and get
your rook on a very active square on f1
here so that's an option that white has
as well always looking for lines that
take away the main advantages from black
which in the well opening is going to be
that v4 square as well as allowing white
to still be very aggressive in their
openings
so we come back let's say that the
bishop does not take on e3 if you're
black i don't actually think that's the
best play because
it's pretty strong if they recapture
with their pawn here so another thing
they could try is d6 they're saying okay
don't want to exchange right here let's
go ahead and open up for light square
bishop
also if you take right here we recapture
that's completely fine now we have a
really strong setup with knight 2
d4 and our queen is eyeing down this
pawn on d3
so i think this is a natural move for
black white's definitely not going to
take the bishop here
instead white's just going to play
knight to f3 just normal development
move here
if they play knight 2 d4
then we're going to play bishop to e2
don't think we want to take here because
the main threat that they have is let's
say we capture with our knight
then they play
pawn takes d4 and this just gets pretty
awkward yes they have double pawns on
the default that's fine because they
have the c pawn over here and it's just
really difficult for us to deal with
this d4 pawn it's very different than if
the knight was here don't have to worry
too much now we can play bishop to f4 if
we want we could bring the bishop back
here c1 but we're not even
going to give them that option because
we're not going to take with our knights
instead we're going to play bishop to e2
now if they want
hey they can take our bishop that's fine
we can go ahead and take with our queen
but more than likely i think they're
going to take our knight we take their
knights
now if they want to exchange the bishops
that's fine
they want to play queen to h4 we could
play g3
you can see this is all fine we're going
to play similar moves as before we can
just bring our queen up to d2 uh protect
this pawn a little bit different setup
than we had before
because they did bring their knight down
and exchange that with our knights but
all in all it's the same principles as
before
we're exchanging so that they don't
control this d4 square with a pawn
before we look at our next variation a
quick word from our sponsor
if you're not familiar with skillshare
it's an online community where you can
take classes on pretty much anything
that you want i just got through going
through mkbhd's
youtube success class really good
content i'm just interested personally
in other big channels and how they
approach youtube how they get engagement
and have high quality content so if
you're interested in skillshare what's
nice is they're giving the first
thousand people to click the link below
in the description as well as the pinned
comments
a free month so if you haven't checked
it out definitely click below and let me
know what you think
so we just looked at when the knight
comes to c6 we play d3 and then bishop
c5 but they don't have to play bishop to
c5 knight to f6 is also logical but
we're still going to continue the same
thing as before bishop to e3
is our play here
now from here they could decide
to go ahead and play
bishop to b4
they're not just going to play bishop c5
we're going to take that that would be a
terrible move so they're not going to
play that so they may look at it and say
how do i actually get my bishop involved
into the game if they play bishop to e7
that's pretty passive and then we can be
the one that's extremely aggressive but
if they want to get their bishop
involved hey that's fine as well we're
just going to play knight to c3 here if
they take
that's always fine we can take here you
can see we're really clogging up the
center of the board definitely not
allowing them to control that d4 square
which is one of our main
weaknesses in the game
but if they don't decide to take that's
fine as well because then we can just
push forward with a3 then almost force
their hand to do something you know if
they castle on the king side we could
play a3 and then where do they really go
they can just bring their bishop back if
they want to you know something like a5
is not that great because then we just
keep pushing forward here and then we
can control this with c5 if they bring
their bishop back so really they almost
need to
be taking here on c3 and then we're in a
fine position right here so that's what
happens if they bring their their bishop
out
we're just going to play that a3
now let's come back this was all based
on if they play
knight to c6
after we play c4 the next version we're
going to look at is if we play is if
black plays knight to f6
in this case white's going to continue
with d3 when i like to approach openings
i like to find lines that are very
simple
it doesn't really matter where my
opponent goes i have the same principles
in my mind and d3 is a core principle in
the whale opening to think about now
they could play very similar to the
knight to c6 variation so if they play a
bishop c5 we're going to be doing the
exact same thing so you don't have to
memorize a lot of new moves it's just
the idea of if they play bishop c5 we
want to play bishop to e3 so that if
they ever exchange we recapture open up
for this f-file so that we can start an
attack on this side as well as
controlling the d4 square we don't just
want to give up that d4 square freely
which a lot of people they look at the
whale opening and think that's what
white's going to do we are not going to
do that by any means so uh if they don't
take it that's fine as well maybe d6
here uh but then we just played bishop
to e2 we can play knight to f3 if we
want to castle on the king side same
theory that we looked at from the first
variation when they played knight to c6
now what if they don't play bishop to c5
they just want to get their knights
involved okay knight to f6 first now
knight to c6
doesn't matter bishop to e3 from us
now one thing to keep in mind maybe they
look at it and say we're not going to
play the bishop game what if they play
pawn
to b6 here
now that's preparing to play bishop to
c5
because you know as we looked at before
they can't just play bishop to c5 once
we have bishop to e3 because then we can
just take their bishop so pawn to b6 may
be an option here but we don't have to
worry too much we're just going to
continue with our same game plan of
developing pieces knight to c3 here
bishop to c5 is fine with us knight to
f3 because we don't care if they take
our bishop on e3 we almost want them to
take that bishop because as soon as they
do we're going to recapture and really
clog up the center of the board
the next variation we're going to look
at is if black plays bishop to c5 you
can see that we can't play bishop e3
right away because our pawn hasn't moved
so you can probably guess what we're
going to play we're going to be playing
pawn to d3 pretty much in most
variations we're going to be playing
pawn to d3 now if they come at the gate
swinging queen 2 h4 and this is really a
beginner mindset of hey the bishop came
to c5 we're attacking the f2 square so
now let's bring our queen over here and
we'll just try to play queen to f2 and
get a quick checkmate okay well that's
obviously not gonna happen against us
we're gonna play pawn g3
okay now how do they really respond to
this there's kind of two
approaches here one is the the more
logical one and that is to recognize
we're not going to give up an easy
checkmate and they play queen to e7 if
they play queen to d8 great hey if you
just want to waste two moves to bring
your queen out and then back to the same
square that's fine as well i think that
would be pretty odd but that's fine from
here we're just going to play knight to
c3 normal development moves as we've
seen
before my guess is though uh that
they're
if they're looking to play queen to h4
that they're they're kind of all in that
they're pot committed and so that's in
that case they may play queen to f6
saying i'm gonna try one more chance to
play queen to f2 we're not gonna allow
that we're gonna play knight to f3
normal development moves but it's a
little bit different now because we have
played pawn to g3 we're gonna fee and
keto our bishop here and so because of
that we're not looking to play the
normal bishop to e3 because we don't
want to play bishop takes on e3 it's a
little awkward with our king set up with
our pawns so now if they play pawn d6
we're going to play
knight 2 c3 because bishop to e3 is just
not as good of a setup once we play that
g3 move from white
so not going to be playing that instead
we're going to be playing knight to c3
this also allows us to come to d5 this
is a great outpost for
our knights remember black is really
eyeing this d4 square we're eyeing this
d5 square so the knight coming to d5 not
only allows us for a great outpost but
it also allows us to continue to attack
the queen on f6 and they're just going
to be moving their queen around
wondering why they haven't checkmated
this yet and then we're just going to
continue to develop our pieces and we're
going to end up with a with a much
better setup now if we play knight to c3
and they play bishop g4 we're gonna
faint head or a bishop to g2 prepare to
castle on the king side and we have a
pretty solid setup from here
instead of the queen coming to h4
they may try
something else knight to c6 now in this
case this goes back to the normal theory
that we've looked at same setup as if
they played knight to c6 first we played
d3 and then bishop c5 you already know
what we're doing now we're playing
bishop to e3 if we haven't fianchettoed
the pawn here to g3 or played g3 and
then fianchetto our bishop to g2 we're
going to be looking to play bishop to e3
so that's what happens if they play
bishop to c5 first the last version
we're going to look at is c6 i don't
really think this is a great option uh
we're pretty much giving the d4 square
to block and telling them hey we're
looking to counter attack in the center
of the board on d4 if you want to go
ahead and take it which most times
black's going to take it
c6 says yeah we want to try to counter
attack you on the light squares but
white has the advantage there but if
they want to that's fine we're going to
play knight to f3 attacking their pawn
forcing them to defend this typically
they would play knight to c6 normal
development square but it's also
defending the pawn on e5 so we're
attacking that pawn and saying you can
no longer bring your knight to c6 so
what say you how are you going to
respond knight to f6 they could try
because if we take they can just play
queen to e7 it gets pretty awkward when
we bring our knight back here and then
they just go ahead and take our pawn on
e4 so if they played knight to f6 we're
actually not going to
to capture that material
instead we're just going to play knight
c3 this says hey you play knight to f6
baiting us a little bit to play knight
takes on e5 but you're also putting
another defender on the d5 square so it
looks like you guys are ready to rumble
in the center but keep in mind in this
position white actually wins the center
battle because let's say they they push
forward with a d5 okay well let's go
through this we take on d5 they take we
take
now they may look at it and say yeah i
can just take with my knight here and
then when you capture they're going to
capture with their queen and then black
has a lot of the initiative
but black has to understand that white's
not going to take this knight there's a
much better move and that move is bishop
to b5 check
because how does black respond now
and if they let's say play bishop to
d7 then we can take and after the queen
takes now we take on e5 we don't take on
d5 we take with our knight on e5 check
now how do they respond okay well one
option would be they take with their
knight on c3 we take they take our queen
we exchange
but then you can see we're getting into
the end game white is already up a pawn
in material so that's better it doesn't
matter that we haven't castled uh once
the queen's off the board castling isn't
as
appropriate now we just want to get all
the material involved into the game and
start to attack here and we're also
threatening
a lot of critical squares with our
knights here so they may try to kick our
knight away maybe pawn f6 that's fine
knight comes back c4
and then
you know blacks down upon a material
diff difficult for them to see how they
actually
respond so if we come back what if they
don't defend with their bishop what if
they say knight to c6
okay well now we can still take with our
knight on e5 we're attacking this knight
on c6 any time a piece is pinned which
this knight is pinned by the bishop you
always want to attack those pieces
knowing that they don't have a lot of
room to do anything with and so black is
in a tough spot so they're going to lose
the center of the board
so that's why i just like playing
a knight to c3 and see how they continue
because they can't just play d5 and
that's why i really don't like the c6
move from black as one of the variations
so that is the whale opening
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video if
you have any other suggestions for one
let me know in the comments below
thank you to our sponsor skillshare
reminder you can click the link in the
description below to get one month free
first thousand people to use that link
will get one month free of skillshare so
thanks again for watching i'll see you
guys in the next video
you